ed sheeran welcome to dilemmas thank you
for having me
um
what happened
okay what's happening here is that i i
want to i want to give you some dilemmas
uh and they can be difficult okay so i i
want you to answer from your heart okay
as true as possible okay okay uh first
fame or fortune
interesting um
i feel like fame comes from something
that people admire you for so i would
say fame
okay so no money but still famous
how would that be can i can i do what i
love
well
i think fame without you can't keep a
guitar fame without the ability to do
what you love would be not that fun
okay next
a fully booked wembley arena or alone in
your private pub line i'm a private pub
yeah okay anyway
yeah well it depends if i if if there's
no i'd have to have something on tap
[Laughter]
would you fight 10 babies ice dragons
or one dragon-sized baby
i reckon 10 baby-sized dragons because
can you imagine the that would come
out of one hand
i'm some size she gives you candy crush
uh king of the dance floor or king at
the bar
king of the dance floor yeah
i feel do you know what i think camera
phones have ruined
like true
dance floor dancing i was at my friend's
30th with uh you know gimme gimme gimme
was on and i was lighting up the dance
floor and i was like i've got this and
my mate filmed me and i watched it back
and i was like oh
i didn't think i looked like that
so if anyone is seeing their friend
dancing and having fun don't fill them
film them because they will remember
that they were the king of the dance
floor yeah i know it's like singing in
the shower i mean when i sing in the
shower it sounds lovely yeah i'm sure it
is lovely no it isn't i'm sorry
i
i've been told
five more kids or five more cats five
more kids but that's not really up to me
i'm not you're gonna have to ask cherry
for that one
uh always give bad advice or always
receive bad advice i reckon always
receive bad advice um because i feel
like there are
a lot a lot of times i meet young
musicians that ask advice and i feel
like they would listen to it and i would
give them bad advice so i feel like
receive bad advice um
because i think i could well it depends
who's giving it
feels like my manager i'd be like yeah i
guess i should do exactly
do the next bond theme or become the
next bomb
i felt the wrath of game of thrones fans
for even appearing as a cameo in game of
thrones can you imagine the wrath
if i was the next bond uh i would do a
bond theme yeah for sure
so elton john or taylor swift
oh man
i don't know
oh um stumped me there they're like
they're like i can't i've been different
yeah i can't you know
yeah but also they're both wonderful
people in my life and i wouldn't be able
to choose
i'm gonna have to um
pass on that one i'm sorry sorry it was
diplomatic yeah
too much sweat or too much perfume
uh can you ever put on too much perfume
can you ever like i find i'm quite i'm
quite a sweaty bloke anyway um like yeah
when i'm on stage i just drip so um
yeah too much perfume
um
what would you say quantity or quality
i mean obviously quality but i feel like
quantity leads to quality the more songs
i write the more i um
you know it's like law law of averages
um the harder you work the luckier you
become so i would say quantity leads to
quality no that's not the right answer
but no but it's a good answer isn't it i
think we have the last one here
never party again
or tattoo the word beer on your forehead
does that mean never drink again i'll
never party again
well never party i could i could deal
with never partying again
but that does that like rule out you
really don't want that tattoo right i
just think it'd be a bit weird i
guess i could wear a hat i could wear a
hat um
where would it be would it be like above
my eyebrow yeah
i think here i have to really pray my
hairline's stuck and i don't think in my
family it does
and sharon it's been wonderful tonight
man thank you so much thank you
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe
you